we have negative three-fourths minus
seven six minus three sixths and there's
many ways to do this but it immediately
jumps out at me that these last two
numbers have a six in the denominator so
I'm going to worry about these first I'm
going to view this as negative 7 6 minus
3 6 so if we have negative 7 6 minus 3 6
that's going to be the same thing as
negative 7 minus 3 over 6 and of course
we have this negative three-fourths out
front that we're going to add to
whatever we get over here so this is
these two terms that I'm adding together
negative 7 minus 3 is negative 10 so
it's negative 10 over 6 and then I'm
going to have to add that to negative
three-fourths to negative I'm using a
negative three-fourths and now I have to
worry about finding a common denominator
let me write that so they look a little
bit they have a similar size negative
three-fourths so now I have to worry
about finding a common denominator what
is the smallest number that is a
multiple of both 4 & 6
well it might jump out of you that it's
12 you can literally just go through the
multiples of 4 or you can look at the
prime factorization of both of these
numbers and what's the smallest number
that has all of the prime factors of
both of these so you need two twos and
you need a 2 and a 3 so if you have two
2s and a 3 that's 4 times 3 is 12 so
let's rewrite this as as something over
12 plus plus something over 12 plus
something over 12 well to get your
denominator from 4 to 12 you have to
multiply by 3 so let's multiply our
numerator by 3 as well so if you
multiply negative 3 times 3 you're going
to have negative 9 and to get your
denominator from 6 to 12 you have to
multiply by 2 so let's multiply our
numerator by 2 as well so that we don't
change the value of the fraction so
that's going to be negative 20 and now
we are ready to add our common
denominator is 12 and so this is going
to be negative 9 negative 9 plus
negative 20 or
even write that as minus 20 over 12
which is equal to and we deserve a drum
roll now this is negative twenty nine
over twelve and twenty nine is a prime
number so it's not going to share any
common factors other than one with
twelve so we also have this in the in
the most simplified form